in part three of our regulation nation
series we look at healthcare while the
Trump administration has not technically
had gotten ridden rid of Obamacare
correspondent Doug mackelway tells us
tonight it is going after one of its
primary sources of funding in a sign of
how urgent it was as the parade was
winding down seven hours into his new
job the new president not yet changed
into his inaugural ball tuxedo he signed
his first executive order in the White
House directing agencies to quote ease
the burden of Obamacare but it was only
symbolic followed six months later by an
all too real defeat as Senator John
McCain cashed in deciding thumbs down on
repeal and replace now taking up a
chisel where the sledgehammer failed mr.
Trump has been chipping away at
Obamacare in October and signed an
executive order allowing insurers to
sell low-cost health insurance with
fewer benefits lasting up to a year it
took effect on Tuesday it also allowed
small businesses to form health
insurance associations across state
lines and directed agencies to consider
changes to health reimbursement
arrangements or HRAs they give employees
more flexibility with company
contributions to pay for out-of-pocket
medical costs or new plans separately
included in the just pass tax bill was
the individual mandates repeal combined
these actions may serve to deprive
Obamacare of what it most needs young
healthy participants it is suffering
from what's called adverse selection
that is people are joining the exchanges
mainly if they're heavily subsidized
also also if they have a health
condition where they can get pretty good
premiums
critics say chipping away at the law is
coming at a cost we have seen that the
efforts to undermine coverage have
driven up premiums for the middle class
for people with pre-existing conditions
so when you see these sorts of efforts
to sabotage the law they're the ones
that really bear the brunt of it does it
mean a death spiral for Obamacare a
basic structure of the law is still
there especially and most importantly
the money because Congress hasn't been
willing to stem its funding Obamacare
lives on although wounded by
president Trump's executive orders but
the stroke of the next presidents pen
may bring it back from the brink
Brett Doug thank you